ya dans toute cette affaire beaucoup
d'hypocrisie les hommes politiques
européens comme secrétaires d'état dont
vous parlez se drape dans des bons
sentiments mais en fait il n'a pas du
tout envie de voir ces migrants venir en
france
[Musique]
on
le spectacle de plusieurs milliers de
jeunes hommes venus du moyen-orient
s'attaquer avec des cisailles et des
pioches à une frontière ceci est
évidemment inacceptable d'autant plus
qu' il y à une sorte de chantage qui
était exercée va le dictateur qui
préside la biélorussie monsieur
loukachenko qui a laissé faire le manège
des trafiquants d'êtres humains
c'est-à-dire deux jeunes hommes
moyen-orientaux qui le tout d'un coup ce
projet d'amour pour la biélorussie et
venaient tous vers minsk en fait et vous
prenez des vols pour minsk pour ensuite
se précipiter à la frontière la pologne
il fallait évidemment bloquer la
fontière tout à fait le droit de
conduire de construire des murs chez soi
il ya dans toute cette affaire beaucoup
d'hypocrisie les hommes politiques
européens comme secrétaires d'état dont
vous parlez se drape dans des bons
sentiments mais en fait il n'a pas du
tout envie de voir ces migrants venir en
france acquart jeu repose en europe sur
son voisin pour faire le sale boulot de
contenir les migrants
[Musique]
le problème qu'on en europe c'est qu'en
septembre 2015 sous le coup de l'émotion
s'agissait de la noyade garçonnet sait
rien sur une côte turque en gala merkel
a décidé d'ouvrir grand les frontières
de l'allemagne pour les refermer un mois
plus tard elle a créé un immense appel
d'air à l'égard de tous les miséreux
d'afrique ou du moyen orient ou d'asie
centrale ce flux n'est pas prêt de se
tarir l'union européenne n'a pas les
moyens économie et la disponibilité
culturel d'accueillir tous ces migrants
l'union européenne
est tout à fait indépendante des
chantages conques d'autres états peuvent
faire que contre elle et elle est aussi
d'un laxisme assez incroyable à l'égard
des trafiquants d'êtres humains
[Musique]
n'ont alors ça serait vraiment le tollé
complotisme d'avoir sort de réunions
entre
loukachenko le biélorusse poutine russe
et bachar al assad le syrien pour aller
ensuite déstabiliser l'union européenne
non je ne crois pas ce genre de complot
les trafiquants d'êtres humains sont
très malins ils ont repéré qu'il y avait
un maillon faible dans cette frontière
le régime de mise de minsk il ya
certainement vu un effet d'aubaine mais
c'est pas monsieur loukachenko qui
lui-même a pensé à cette affaire il est
vrai que la russie de vladimir poutine
est le principal allié international de
la biélorussie on pense que la lumière
poutine veut déstabiliser l'europe s'est
d'ailleurs pas son intérêt il vient de
mettre en pratique contrat ghazi très
important avec l'allemagne il ne
contrôle pas entièrement l'occassion qu
il derrière lui il est contre un
mouvement démocratique en biélorussie
mais loukachenko est un sanguin
quelqu'un qu'on contrôle mal poutine va
certainement en faire tous ses efforts
pour le ramener à la raison c'est à dire
la raison pour laquelle emmanuel patron
a
appelé son homologue vladimir poutine
[Musique]